let's talk about the strikes um should
we um formal leveling up secretary Simon
Clark your predecessor criticized nurses
for not budgeting their finances
properly if they need to use feed Banks
Jillian Keegan saying no she's only
turned to feedbacks when a relationship
or a boiler has broken down do you agree
with your cabinet colleagues that nurses
are excellent at saving lives but
hopeless with their finances
uh no I would never put it that way I
think we appreciate that nurses everyone
who's working on the front line in the
National Health Service is not only
doing an amazing job and
um Mike thanks and gratitude to nurses
uh uh today is something I want to
express very deeply and personally I
also think that when we're looking at
the uh the pay claims that are being
made but by people within the National
Health Service and also people in other
parts of the public sector we have to
balance uh making sure that we do
everything we can to reward them for
their hard work with recognizing that we
also have to be careful stewards of
public money overall and what we can't
do is necessarily exceed to every demand
in the public sector for pay increases
because uh we don't want to be in a
position where the public finances
overall are out of control
yeah so your colleagues are wrong to
criticize the way nurses manage their
money
I would never criticize uh nurses for uh
uh something like that I think the most
important thing to do is to recognize
the people who are working in the NHS
are people who've dedicated their lives
to a caring profession they're doing
everything they can to support us I know
myself in recent weeks having seen the
NHS uh close up front and personal uh
the dedicated care that nurses and
others who work in the National Health
Service give and of course we want to do
everything possible in order to make
sure that people are paid well and in
accordance with their their skills and
respecting their commitment but we also
have to balance that against the need as
I say to make sure that uh that public
funds are spent wisely I hope that
you're fully recovered um from having to
use the National Health Service
previously and that your health has
recovered thank you for sharing that
with us and what about this coordinated
um strike action with nurses ambulance
workers and emergency call handlers on
the 6th of February how responsible is
it of those workers to all strike on the
same day
well naturally we wouldn't we would
prefer the not to be any strikes at all
we prefer the not to be coordinated
strike action of this kind I just say
two things uh the first is that I'm
conscious that uh ambulance workers
nurses and others uh when they do go on
strike action and I don't approve of it
I have to say but they do take steps in
order to ensure that they can uh look
after the the most urgent emergency
cases the second thing that I would say
is that we are introducing legislation
to make sure that there is a minimum
service level that should provide people
with peace of mind that there will
always be an NHS there for them and
indeed other blue light services that
they need it's just unfortunate that
other parties in the House of Commons
labor and the liberal Democrats won't
support that legislation in order to
make sure that there will be a minimum
level of service for everyone
you're in Blackpool today 40 million
pounds for a new carbon neutral
multiversity in Blackpool and people
can't afford what they're heating on in
Blackpool
um are you not are you going at it the
wrong way
no this is I think the fourth time I've
been in Blackpool this year and the
reason I'm here is that uh we want to
level up the whole country we want to
make sure that in areas like Blackpool
that have been overlooked and
undervalued in the past there's an
investment in the future so earlier this
year we invested 30 million pounds in
helping to regenerate the the very heart
of Black Gold Spring new jobs and
investment here and today we're
announcing 40 million pounds for a new
uh higher education campus here a
multiversity which will ensure that
young people in Blackpool get the sorts
of opportunities that young people are
in the in the rest of the country have
had if we're going to make sure that
people get the the sort of high earning
jobs which will guarantee there and
their family's future we need to invest
now in education and nowhere is more
important than here in the northwest
yeah you say that but while running for
um prime minister in the summer a video
emerges as an eye prime minister
admitting he took money from deprived
areas to give it to other parts of the
country rather flies in the face of what
you've just said
well the proof actually is what the
prime minister is doing and what we're
doing today
um that's more than two billion pounds
being spent to more than 100 projects
across the United Kingdom and the areas
that are benefiting places like
Blackpool and morecombe and cleethorpes
and Wigan these are areas which have
been overlooked in the past by previous
governments but this government is
absolutely committed to leveling up to
spreading opportunity and to investing
in the future and making sure that
people have uh whether it's investment
in higher education here or investment
in economic activity elsewhere the
opportunity to prosper in the future
yeah we're amiss not to mention Richmond
in that list as well I would suggest of
course the constituency of the Prime
Minister they're receiving 19 million
pounds as part of this handing out of
cash our cash it's been described as the
Posh part of Yorkshire the Surrey of the
north and income deprivation down to 22
as opposed to Blackpool where it's 60
one percent
well we are giving money to catrick but
that money is going to the uh the
biggest Army infantry base in the
country
um again over recent weeks I've had an
opportunity to talk to service families
about their accommodation I don't think
anyone would deny but investing money in
making sure that our service families
have absolutely the best circumstances
to support them I think anyone would
deny that is a good use of money and if
people want to say that service families
and that the catterick Garrison doesn't
deserve cash then let them
uh okay let me I'm sure they will let me
ask you about wig and you talked about
Wigan which of course is where your
opposite
um number resides representing the good
people of Wigan the leader of the
council 20 million quid or thereabouts
for hey Hall where I got married
actually
um the council say although we are
relieved to have received confirmation
of the funding for hey Hall our concerns
about the leveling up fund system remain
and we would continue to urge the
government to find a more appropriate
way to deliver the investment local
areas like ours deserve
well again you can't always necessarily
expect gratitude in politics but I do
think it is a good thing that we're
contributing millions of pounds uh to
Wigan
um the investment in Hay Hall is an
investment that the council itself
argued for and again the uh the
inference was from from the previous
question that some not UK but some would
be criticizing the money that's going to
catrick to help Army families
um this is money that is going to the
constituency as you quite rightly point
out of my opposite number labor MP Lisa
nandy so we have objective criteria that
govern where money is going we look at
the Strategic fit the deliverability the
economic benefits and Heritage matters
as well so that investment in Hay Hall
is an investment in wigan's future okay
but the announcement leaves out to a lot
of the more deprived areas in the UK
disproportionately benefiting
conservative areas I'm told of the 80
successful bids only half are in the 100
most deprived areas of the country
well there are areas of deprivation
across the whole United Kingdom I think
it is the case actually that more labor
local authorities than conservative
local authorities receive money but it
will be news to people in cleethorpes or
in workington who are receiving money
today that they're not areas of of uh of
of high need areas that have been
undervalued in the past